so i've had this problem for a really
long time where i find myself just
getting sucked into my phone
i think it's just for a few seconds here
and there to look at a headline
but in reality it looks a little more
like this it's not a great look
and honestly i'd like to set a better
example for my kids
recently in order to try to break me
this habit i've been asking my wife to
film me so i can actually see what this
looks like
i don't know that i could say it's done
anything to cure me but it definitely is
effective in making me stop
now you can see evidence of surveillance
as a means of curbing bad behavior
all over and in workplaces many
employees have been under surveillance
by their employer
for a long time but as the pandemic has
forced many jobs to be remote
that surveillance has now followed
employees home
some companies this morning are starting
to monitor their employees more closely
than ever
they track what you click on where you
go on the internet
everything you type into your keyboard
employee surveillance has boomed during
the pandemic
and the software that goes along with it
is flying off the virtual shelves
and these tools do more than just watch
and plays they analyze
rank and report on their productivity
and it's likely to become just another
part
of our future of work
[Music]
now digital privacy in the workplace
isn't a new subject when you're at work
on a computer you might think that what
you're doing is actually private
well you might want to think again
there's a pretty good chance your boss
is eavesdropping on
everything you do as long as there's
been closed circuit tv there have been
cameras
in offices that monitor what people are
doing
this is bennett ciphers a staff
technologist for the electronic
frontiers foundation
he's been investigating recent employee
surveillance technology or
as he refers to it bossware we've looked
at about a dozen different uh products
in this space
and what all of them do to start is
monitor like activity like high level
activity so it's like what apps are
people using
and what websites are they visiting but
as bennett explains many of these
software tools go a few steps further
capturing screenshots of your desktop or
recording every time you move your mouse
and logging every single key that you
strike if you like log in to your bank
account or something
and when you type in your password it
shows up as a bunch of stars or a bunch
of dots
a key logger or keystroke logger will
have collected
every input that went in to that website
and so they would they would be able to
see your password as well even if you
can't actually see it on the screen
there are some products that do let
their clients
turn on webcams and microphones secretly
and record
through people's devices but i really
can't say how much adoption they have
and i do think that that is
not the norm big brother perhaps
but it's perfectly legal for businesses
to keep an unblinking eye on employees
as long as they disclose it before they
do it even prior to the pandemic there
were already signs that this kind of
software was on the rise
a 2018 survey by gartner of 239
large companies showed a dramatic rise
in the adoption of this software
and in the time of covet for employers
many see it as a means to return
some sense of normalcy you know
traditionally
pre in a pre-coveted pre-work from home
universe
companies had line of sight i'm a
manager i'm a supervisor i'm an owner i
show up at the office
i can see who's there i can see who's
not there i can see
whether people are sitting at their desk
and working or whether they're on their
phone with their feet kicked up
i can see all those things this is brad
miller he's the ceo of the surveillance
software maker inner guard
and he says that after the pandemic
struck the company saw over a 300
growth in their customer base sharing
this tab okay good so it's sharing
okay so you you can see my screen i can
see your screen yep
you're you're looking at at the
dashboard here
um and the dashboard has a few different
views depending upon
what part of the company you're in so
you're looking at the chart view right
now
which is looking at high level data is
typically used by executives
the next view which is probably the most
used view
is the user view what this view is
trying to cr
is trying to recreate that line of sight
that they used to have when everybody
was
in the office in case this isn't obvious
all the data here is fake
and they're using characters from the
show the office to essentially
illustrate some of the selling points of
the software
and so as an example here i can see andy
is a 40 hour a week employee he was
logged in this week for 37
of those 40 hours and you know
not all of that time that he was logged
in was active
and then not all of the active time is
productive
each of these circles kind of gives a
breakdown of an employee's day
gray is idle blue is productive
red is not productive and yellow is
neutral
and so in a very quick view i can just
quickly
you know glance at my employees did they
show up for work are they generally
showing up on time
do they look you know reasonably busy
and if something seems off
intercar gives you more tools to sort of
drill down into an employee's day
if you see something suspicious like say
a lot of inactive time
you can investigate to see their
calendar a large
chunk of inactive time can suddenly be
explained away
by a party planning committee meeting
followed by a
hour-long film screening you could also
choose to flip through screenshots of
what the employee was doing on their
computer that day
or even set up alert words so that you
can be notified if something suspicious
is happening right away i can single it
on this one here
jim halpert it was a keystroke data type
and i can see that there was
a couple of alert words highlighted in
here you know
the word file and the word kaplan the
idea here is a sort of cache an employee
who might be say
sharing client files with a competitor
and while there are a lot of other tools
here to help investigate different forms
of employee theft or
inappropriate behavior brad says that
lately that's not the most common use
what's different now in the world of
covid and work from home
is that we now see big companies uh
trying to
not just use us for investigations but
rather more
in terms of confirming time
attendance and productivity scoring
productivity or
ranking productivity is found in many of
the different employee surveillance
software on the market today
interguard allows admins to flag what
programs or websites are considered
productive unproductive or neutral
and using a fairly simple equation adds
them all together that generate a daily
score for each employee
and you know in our data-driven world
there is something about this that makes
a lot of sense to me
i mentioned before my issue with looking
at my phone too much
well applications like screen time on my
iphone will show me a day-to-day
collection of how i spend my time
making being aware of say how obsessive
i am with my fantasy football team
easier than ever before mass
surveillance is often
convenient that's that's why the people
who do it do it
one thing that surveillance does sort of
across the board in every context that's
used in is
exacerbate power imbalances whether it's
a government surveilling its people
whether it's like a giant corporation
surveilling its customers and as
competitors
or whether it's in this case like a
company surveilling the people who work
for it
your your employer has interests which
involve you and don't always align with
yours and they're
frequently situations where your
employer might want
to know uh what you were doing last
night
or might want to like dig up
dirt or like no no like have some sort
of weapon to use against you and some
sort of dispute between
you and the company brad points to
features in inner guard meant to protect
the privacy of employees
like being able to set the working hours
for users so you can avoid capturing any
non-work related actions
but he also makes it clear that for the
system to work for both employee and
employer
it needs to be done transparently we
tend to educate
our customers to be transparent with the
use of the software
there's really no point if you want to
use inner guard as a tool to manage
productivity
if i don't tell you it's on there well
then how am i getting value from it i
mean because
fundamentally i want to be able to say
hey i see you're only logged in four
hours today
where did i get that information from
you know we all behave a little bit
better when we know someone's watching
and it's a it it's a tricky line for
sure
um but in my view that can all be
navigated easily
by being transparent
typically people default to technology
something's wrong
quick let's buy a machine or a program
this is marie gervais
she's the ceo of shift management a
company that specializes in
improving work spaces through leadership
development and from talking to her she
points out that transparency is really
just a starting point as an employer
you also need to think about your intent
so if your intent is to
hone down and just like who can i catch
doing something wrong
well that's all your energy is going to
go to that but if your energy is hmm
how can we make things better and how
can i resource you so we can make things
better what you pay attention to grows
but if you're looking to catch mistakes
that's all you're going to catch and
marie explains that in order to have
focus intent you really need to shorten
the amount of time that you use this
technology
so if you want to roll out surveillance
software say this is what we're thinking
of doing and this is why
and then the target needs to be short so
okay we're gonna try this for a week
we're gonna try this for two weeks we'll
try this for a month no longer than that
because then people just get really
frustrated if everyone knows they're
being surveilled all the time
they act differently and they are more
afraid
of stepping outside of the bounds
of what they consider to be the behavior
that is expected of them i mean if
you're a very controlling manager maybe
that's
your goal but in a lot of cases i think
that can actually hurt
uh productivity and creativity i have an
employee who
had surveillance software with her
previous employer i mean if she would be
gone to the bathroom
the employer went after where were you
you were gone for four point
you know six minutes and she goes to the
bathroom well why
when she started working with me she
said where's your surveillance software
and i said i don't have any
she went woohoo and then what happened
is she stopped
producing stuff because she was so used
to being treated like a assembly line
employee that she didn't have the skills
to actually run her job properly
for three years she was under the
surveillance software and she had to
kind of heal from it
actually because it wasn't used properly
as the current evidence suggests
the future of work is likely to feature
more remote or
flexible working employees post-covet
and it's likely many of these employees
will need to use some kind of
surveillance software
as an employee if i knew that the pro
quo
for me being able to continue working
from home post covid
was knowing that my employer was
confirming my productivity and
attendance
i make that trade every day and twice on
sunday we're at sort of this inflection
point where
it's been around but it's getting a lot
more popular and it's gonna be a lot
more prevalent going forward
and i think it's just dawning on a lot
of people that
they might be working in this world in
the future where
their device is being surveilled they're
being surveilled all the time and
there's whenever you have that sort of
change especially rapid change
that is an opportunity to change the
the way the world works around it and i
think we can do the same thing
in the worker privacy space